I would never leave my baby in my wife
Ray J is setting the record straight on
the current relationship status with his
wife Princess luv
settle down boys and girls settle down
last month the two reportedly got into a
heated argument after the Soul Train
Awards in Las Vegas resulting in Ray J
allegedly leaving princess and their
one-year-old daughter melody on the side
of the road Princess is also 8 months
pregnant with their second child people
say a lot of stuff is what I'm saying
princess later took to Instagram to
share details of her situation writing
quote yes I can fly home I have my own
money but my cars here and I don't want
to drive back alone with my daughter
because I'm over 8 months pregnant
and I don't even want to have to stop
for gas or go into labor with all this
human trafficking going on Ray J finally
put the rumors to rest Wednesday on the
Wendy Williams Show look it didn't
happen like that I would never leave my
baby and my wife so I'll die first
before I lead him on well where were you
well they were at the hotel and that's
what she considers stranded at the time
look she's right I'm not gonna even
defend it
whatever is wrong we fighting you're
right a source recently told ET that Ray
J and princess are not currently
together as a couple and are not
attending couples counseling hold on
stop the press et has also learned that
princess is still very much considering
filing for divorce from her husband of
three years but Ray J seems to be in it
for the long haul I would never get
married if it wasn't super locked
between us I think well we got to work
on is just keeping our circle tight
which is just me her and our baby
[Music]